Saviez-vous que l'année dernière, pendant 299 jours,
nous n'avons utilisé aucun combustible fossile
pour générer toute notre électricité ?
C'est une prouesse fantastique
et, pourtant, elle cache un paradoxe :
le pétrole constitue près de 70% de notre consommation d'énergie.
Pourquoi ?
À cause de notre système de transport
qui est totalement dépendant des énergies fossiles,
comme c'est le cas dans la plupart des pays.
Si l'on considère la transition énergétique comme un marathon,
la question est : comment arriver à la ligne d'arrivée ?
Comment dé-carboniser le reste de l'économie ?
Il est juste de dire que si nous, nous n'y arrivons pas,
on ne sait pas bien qui le pourra.
C'est pour cette raison que je voudrais vous parler du Costa Rica.
Parce que je pense que nous sommes un excellent candidat
pour proposer une vision du développement sans énergies fossiles.
S'il y a une chose à retenir de notre pays,
c'est que nous n'avons pas d'armée.
Je vais vous renvoyer à l'année 1948.
Cette année-là, le pays sortait d'une guerre civile.
Des milliers de Costaricains sont morts
et les familles étaient déchirées.
Pourtant, une idée surprenante a gagné les cœurs et les esprits :
nous allions tout reconstruire dans le pays
et la Deuxième République n'aurait pas d'armée.
Nous l'avons donc abolie.
Et le président de cette époque,
José Figueres,
s'est fait comprendre en détruisant les murs d'une base militaire.
L'année suivante, en 1949,
cette décision a été prise définitivement dans la nouvelle constitution,
voilà pourquoi je peux vous en parler près de 70 ans plus tard.
J'en suis reconnaissante,
reconnaissante qu'ils aient pris cette décision avant que je naisse
car ça m'a permis, à moi et à des millions d'autres,
de vivre dans un pays très stable.
Vous pourriez croire que c'était un coup de chance,
mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Il y a eu un ensemble de choix délibérés.
Dans les années 40, les Costaricains ont eu l'éducation et les soins gratuits.
Nous avons appelé cela les garanties sociales.
En abolissant l'armée,
nous avons été en mesure de transférer les dépenses militaires vers le social,
ce qui a été un moteur de stabilité.
Dans les années 50 --
(Applaudissements)
Dans les années 50, on a commencé à investir dans l'hydroélectricité,
et ça nous a évité de tomber dans le piège de l'utilisation des carburants fossiles
pour produire de l'électricité,
chose dont le monde essaie de se défaire aujourd'hui.
Dans les années 70, on a investi dans les parcs nationaux
et ça nous a éloignés
de la logique profondément viciée de la croissance à tout prix
que tous acceptent, surtout dans les pays en développement.
Dans les années 90, on a lancé
les paiements pour les services écosystémiques,
qui nous aidèrent à inverser la déforestation
et à stimuler l'écotourisme, aujourd'hui moteur clé de la croissance.
Investir dans la protection de l'environnement
n'a donc pas nui à notre économie.
C'est plutôt l'inverse.
Cela ne signifie pas que nous sommes parfaits,
ou qu'il n'y a pas d'incohérences.
Ce n'est pas le sujet.
Le sujet, c'est qu'en faisant nos propres choix,
nous avons pu développer une résilience face aux problèmes du développement.
Aussi, si vous prenez un pays comme le nôtre,
le PIB par habitant est d'environ 11 000 dollars,
selon la façon comment vous le mesurez.
Mais selon l'indice de progrès social,
nous sommes hors norme
quand il s'agit de transformer le PIB en progrès social.
Abolir l'armée,
investir dans la nature et la population,
a fait quelque chose d'incroyable aussi.
Ça a façonné l'histoire,
l'histoire d'un petit pays avec de grandes idées,
et ça a été très valorisant de grandir avec ce récit.
La question est donc :
quelle est la prochaine grande idée pour cette génération ?
Et je crois que ce qui vient ensuite, c'est pour cette génération
d'abandonner les énergie fossiles une bonne fois pour toutes,
comme nous l'avons fait avec l'armée.
Les énergies fossiles créent le réchauffement climatique, on le sait.
Et on sait combien on est vulnérables aux impacts du changement climatique.
Alors en tant que pays en développement, c'est dans notre intérêt
de concevoir un développement sans énergies fossiles,
chose qui a toujours causé du tort aux gens.
Car...
pourquoi continuer d'importer du pétrole
pour le transport
si on peut utiliser l’électricité à la place ?
Rappelez-vous,
c'est le pays
dont l'électricité provient de l'eau des rivières,
de la chaleur des volcans,
des éoliennes, des panneaux solaires
et des biodéchets.
Abolir les énergies fossiles veut dire modifier notre système de transport
afin d'alimenter nos voitures, bus et trains avec de l'électricité
au lieu de l'énergie polluante.
Et le transport, laissez-moi vous dire,
est devenu une question existentielle pour nous, les Costaricains,
parce que ce modèle ne marche pas pour nous.
Il fait souffrir les gens,
il cause du tort aux entreprises,
et il est mauvais pour notre santé.
Car lorsque les lois et les infrastructures échouent,
voici ce qu'il se passe tous les jours.
Deux heures le matin, deux heures le soir.
Je ne comprends pas pourquoi nous devrions accepter ça.
C'est outrageant
d'avoir à perdre notre temps comme ça chaque jour.
Cette autoroute est en fait plutôt bien
comparée à ce que l'on voit ailleurs
où le trafic est en pleine explosion.
Au Costa Rica, on appelle ça « presa. »
« Presa » signifie « emprisonné ».
Les gens deviennent violents
dans un pays qui est pourtant heureux dans sa « pura vida ».
C'est ce qu'il se passe.
Il y a beaucoup en jeu.
La bonne nouvelle,
c'est que, quand on parle de transport propre
et de mobilité différente,
on ne parle pas d'une utopie lointaine.
On parle d'une mobilité électrique qui existe aujourd'hui.
D'ici 2022, les voitures électriques et les voitures classiques
devraient coûter le même prix,
et les villes essaient déjà les bus électriques.
Ces engins vraiment cools
économisent de l'argent,
et réduisent la pollution.
Si on veut se débarrasser du transport basé sur le pétrole, on le peut,
car on a maintenant des options que l'on n'avait pas avant.
C'est vraiment excitant.
Mais bien sûr,
certains deviennent très mal à l'aise face à cette idée
et ils viendront vous dire
que le monde ne peut pas se passer de pétrole
et le Costa Rica non plus, alors arrêtez de rêver.
Voilà ce qu'ils vous disent.
Vous savez quoi répondre à cet argument ?
Qu'en 1948, nous n'avons pas dit que l'on ne pouvait pas se passer d'armée,
que nous devions donc la garder.
Non, nous avons fait un choix très courageux,
et ce choix a fait la différence.
Il est donc temps pour cette génération d'être courageuse à nouveau
et d'abolir les énergies fossiles.
Je vais vous donner trois raisons de le faire.
Premièrement,
notre système de transport et d'urbanisation ne fonctionne plus,
c'est donc le moment de redéfinir notre avenir en urbanisme et en mobilité.
Nous ne voulons pas de villes construites pour les voitures,
nous voulons des villes pour les gens,
où l'on peut marcher et faire du vélo.
Et nous voulons des transports publics,
beaucoup,
des transports publics qui soient propres et dignes.
Parce que si nous agrandissons la flotte de voitures classiques,
nos villes deviendront insupportables.
Deuxièmement, il faut changer,
mais un changement graduel ne sera pas suffisant.
Il faut un changement transformationnel.
Il y a des projets graduels dans mon pays
et je suis la première à les saluer.
Mais arrêtons de nous voiler la face.
On ne parle pas d'avoir de jolies voitures électriques ici
et quelques bus électriques là,
tout en continuant d'investir dans le même genre d'infrastructure,
plus de voitures, plus de routes, plus de pétrole.
On parle de se libérer du pétrole
et vous ne pouvez pas y arriver graduellement.
Troisièmement, et ça vous le savez,
le monde a faim d'inspiration.
Il raffole d'histoires de succès
face aux questions complexes,
en particulier dans les pays en développement.
Je crois que le Costa Rica peut être une source d'inspiration pour les autres,
comme nous l'avons fait l'année dernière, en dévoilant que pendant tant de jours,
nous n'avions pas utilisé d'énergies fossiles
pour générer notre électricité.
La nouvelle s'est propagée dans le monde entier.
Aussi, et ça me rend très fière,
une femme costaricaine, Christiana Figueres,
a joué un grand rôle dans les négociations de l'accord de Paris sur le climat.
Nous devons donc protéger cet héritage et être un exemple.
Alors qu'est-ce qui vient après ?
Les gens.
Comment amener les gens à s'emparer de ce problème ?
Comment amener les gens
à croire qu'il est possible
de construire une société sans énergies fossiles ?
Un énorme travail sur le terrain est nécessaire.
C'est pourquoi, en 2014, nous avons créé Costa Rica Limpia.
« Limpia » signifie « propre »,
parce que nous voulons responsabiliser et inspirer les citoyens.
Si les citoyens ne s'impliquent pas,
les décisions sur le transport propre seront bloquées
par des discussions techniques absolument sans fin
et par une avalanche de lobbying de la part des personnes en place.
Vouloir être un pays vert alimenté par les énergies renouvelables
fait déjà partie de notre histoire.
Il ne faut laisser personne nous le reprendre.
L'an dernier, nous avons rassemblé des gens venant de nos sept provinces
pour parler de changement climatique d'une façon qui les touche
et nous avons aussi invité, cette année,
un autre groupe de Costaricains
pour parler de l'énergie renouvelable.
Et vous savez quoi ?
Ces gens étaient en désaccord sur presque tout,
hormis sur les énergies renouvelables,
le transport propre et l'air pur.
Ça rassemble vraiment les gens.
La clé pour une participation réelle,
c'est d'aider les gens à ne pas se sentir petits.
Les gens se sentent impuissants
et ils sont fatigués de ne pas être entendus.
Ce qu'on fait, ce sont des choses concrètes
et nous traduisons les problèmes techniques dans le langage des citoyens
pour montrer que les citoyens ont un rôle à jouer et peuvent collaborer.
Pour la première fois, nous tenons les promesses qui ont été faites
sur le transport propre
et les politiciens savent qu'ils doivent agir,
mais la bascule arrivera lorsque nous formerons des coalitions --
citoyens, entreprises,
garants du transport en commun --
cela fera de la mobilité électrique une nouvelle norme,
en particulier, dans les pays en développement.
D'ici les prochaines élections,
je crois que tous les candidats devront faire savoir où ils se situent
sur l'abolition des énergies fossiles.
Car cette question doit entrer dans notre politique générale.
Et je vous promets que ce n'est pas une question de politique climatique
ou de programme environnemental.
Il est question du pays que nous voulons,
des villes que nous avons,
des villes que nous voulons
et de ceux qui font ce choix.
Parce qu'au final, ce que nous devons montrer,
c'est que le développement avec les énergies renouvelables
est bon pour les gens,
pour les Costaricains qui vivent aujourd'hui
et surtout pour ceux qui ne sont pas encore nés.
Voici notre musée national.
Il est lumineux et paisible
et, quand vous vous trouvez devant,
il est difficile de croire que c'était une caserne
à la fin des années 40.
Nous avons commencé une nouvelle vie sans armée à cet endroit
et c'est là que notre abolition
des combustibles fossiles sera un jour annoncée.
Et nous ferons l'histoire à nouveau.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)